well the Special Counsel investigation
is accelerating at some point possibly
soon we're going to see Robert Muller's
report or parts of it it was not
released to the public parts of it will
certainly be leaked we'll have that
information the question is how should
we assess it Alan Dershowitz has thought
a lot about this question he's a retired
Harvard Law School professor author of
the case against impeaching Trump and he
joins us tonight professor thanks for
coming on so are we likely to see this
report in whole or part and what should
we think when we do
well first we will eventually see much
of the report probably the whole report
eventually but we should never see it
until we also see the president's legal
team rebuttal because otherwise it's a
completely one-sided presentation
remember it's like an indictment even
though it won't be an indictment it's
one-sided it's based on the testimony
only of witnesses of the prosecution so
what the call and as everybody knows an
indictment can't be used as evidence of
guilt it doesn't undercut the
presumption of innocence it's just a
charging document and that's the way we
ought to read the report issued by
Muller it's simply an accusation and we
must see the other side of the story
before we can come to any conclusion
somehow people think it deserves more
credibility because it's a Special
Counsel report but that's not true
Special Counsel is just another
prosecutor looking at one side of the
case and he will present a one-sided
account which will be very critical of
his subjects so the report there's no
requirement that the report has balance
in it or shows both sides of any
question
quite the opposite it's a prosecutorial
report it will not show balance anybody
who expects balance fairness nuance it's
looking at the wrong kind of document
you can't have balance when you haven't
heard the other side of the story when
you haven't called witnesses who might
be exculpatory when you've only tried to
put together a prosecutorial case and
that's why it's essential that the
president's team be permitted to issue
their own report at the same time the
Muller report is issued interesting so
the people who said we need a special
counsel investigation to find out what
happened as an informational exercise
we're lying to us so let me ask you a
more fundamental question about this
absolutely yeah
so every person who wields power in our
society by design has some sort of
oversight we can we can defeat our
elected representatives and elections we
can recall or impeach or President or
judges the special counsel we're told
can't be fired because that itself would
be an impeachable offense so is there
oversight of any kind of the special
counsel well first of all firing the
special counsel would not be an
impeachable offense because it wouldn't
be a crime the president would have the
authority to do it it would be
politically very damaging today would
look technically there is oversight over
the special counsel in the percentage of
the Attorney General of course our
Attorney General was recused now we have
an acting Attorney General but the
regulations provide that the Attorney
General is not supposed to micromanage
the work of the special counsel he's not
like any other US attorney who's under
the direct supervision the ultimate
control the Attorney General has is
whether to release the report under what
circumstances to release the report
whether to redact parts of the report
whether to reject parts of the report
and send it back to the special counsel
and say look you didn't do a good enough
job go back to the drawing board and do
it again it's unlikely any of those
things will occur except I think that
the Attorney General would be wise to
demand that before the special council
report is released to the public or even
to Con
that the president's legal team be given
an opportunity to review and rebut it
and provide their own report then the
American public in Congress can see both
sides in tandem and make an intelligent
decision as to where the right is and
how to bring nuance and find the truth
the truth is best achieved through an
adversarial process through presenting
all sides of an issue not presenting one
side of an issue that's the whole
premise of this show by the way
professor thank you great to see you
tonight thank you